what's up everybody it's your boy Travis
under here
we're back in another onesie back with
another live stream about to go crazy
today got a good lock screen set so
y'all in My Fit
got the shoes
drip a lot if you go hard this week yes
sir all right this week here in
Blackburn and I decided to get together
show some love to each other
make a video it's your boy Travis under
here we're back with another Banger we
got a special guest come on in man
what's up with you what up how we doing
how we doing good go ahead and let the
people know who you is you know they're
talking heavy Blackburn you don't play
CSU we just we just played uh last last
weekend or last Saturday
you know I was just making sure my my
guys straight yeah you know just making
sure he's good checking in with them I
know we we talked after the game on the
phone and then through the DMS and stuff
and make this happen for the people that
love to see negativity they're saying a
negative video man it's great positive
and you know how we get it's done but
positivity this way
amen that's just us you know coming
together letting everybody know it's all
positive positivity around the world man
you just gotta be willing to forgive and
forget and just accept that it happened
already I mean it's just us knowing that
we're a young man it's not a lot of
young people like us going out each day
even though somebody made a mistake we
come together and then just show the
people that at the end of the day was
all a mistake
you gotta have respect for each other
and that's what my biggest thing is to
do is to show people the positive side
of me
I don't like to be negative I'm not
negative it's hard to get me angry it's
like me and him coming together just
showed a different side of the world at
like
it's actually nice people out in the
world and there's always going to be
some positivity around my name
so
that's what that is that's how it is
I'm good man day by day week by week
minute by minute hour by hour I'm
getting better so
that's all it is
that's great
I will I will get better
I'm gonna do yes sir I've always been a
good man good dude I don't like negative
stuff man
it just doesn't do anything but make
your mind going around and around in the
circle
so what's up what's up what's up all
right
so this weekend we had a game it felt
great for me to be back on uh on the
side line I haven't seen my team in a
minute I would I can't go back up there
because it's like well I could go back
up there now but
couldn't go up there because it's just
like
it hurts it hurts to go out there and
try to see the see the players go out
there and just
knowing I can't help it hurts I mean
like half time I didn't want to come
back out
it's hurt me not being able to go out
there in full gear ready to go out there
compete and try to get my team the best
shot
see I heard but it felt good at the same
time going on that semi my boys come
back and do what they did best oh also
yeah Jalen Brown and Derek white stopped
by a talk had a little conversation with
him
is that there talking
they're showing love man that's big man
am I gonna watch them boys is actually
big they actually big but they look
small on TV I don't know how that works
yeah let's get it drive yes sir
uh thoughts on Jew Holiday trade that's
helping the Celtics I mean I I like the
trade
up in the Celtics at the end of the day
I mean I don't know if it's a good I
don't think he thinks it's a good trade
I don't know do I think I'm a better DPO
receiver I mean I don't know man I just
goddamn played both as hard as I can to
best of my ability at any time nah let
me go where I'm at
the baby also put up to the games too so
that was good seeing the baby he showed
some love too
that's that's all it's always love when
celebrities come out man I got nothing
but respect for them and come down
showing us love showing that support
I mean that's
that's just like
you know you have some you have
celebrities behind you no matter what
win a loss they still behind you so it's
actually good for us I accept it I like
when they come out and support us it
means a lot to the team means a lot to
me means a lot to coach prom
you've seen Jokers didn't know who coach
prom is yeah I seen that just now before
I came back downstairs
but
hey jokish is not from uh USA so
I mean I went he don't think he watched
football either so
I wouldn't expect him to know coach prom
with some of the best advice playmaker
or Tio gave to me uh stay focused
stay focused main thing don't get the
big kid always be willing to learn
uh just go out and do my thing basically
man just don't let anybody take me try
to get me outside of my game play my
game I mean that's pretty much all the
things they told me so far that I still
hold on to
they let me know to yo show me a couple
routes and stuff help me out a little
bit so
that's all Insight that we can let y'all
know but yeah he let me he he taught me
a couple rounds of stuff helped me run
routes so I'm trying to trying to hop in
the studio nah I'm good
I'm a rock man
when I'm coming back don't know yet man
hopefully it's soon I don't know
I'm doing better though
I'm starting to get back to myself
after talking all that mess how does it
feel to be humble and I'm just out of
the top 25 I mean bro nobody cares about
the top 25 we don't
you've never seen us talk mess bro we
just go out and play our game we do what
we do we don't care about other teams
hey that's don't let our confidence make
you feel like we're talking mess or
like we don't care bro we just go out
there and do and play how we play we do
our thing not anybody else thing you
know top three rappers ah
quavo
Lil Durk little baby I like auto man Rod
wave Lil Wayne definitely Lil Wayne Lil
Wayne and stop at the top be listening
away oh my God
well I'm going crazy everything you hear
about Lil Wayne he on that mug snapping
so yeah Lil Wayne go crazy Lil Wayne
cuevo La baby Le dirt
man they be snapping man am I gonna play
a Colorado next year yes I'm not going
anywhere
some of the cameras call me uh coaching
up for money also during the game I mean
I was just been in this here you know
he's a young player you still gotta
learn a lot to learn I'm just been in
this here let me know what I see every
time I told him something he listened
and it worked out good for him I mean I
knew some of the routes halfway through
the game I'm like huh
they only ran these couple hours of
money
when he right here you know where he
going and they didn't try to attack him
over the top they tried him one time
over the top I'm like
yeah money you ain't gotta don't worry
about going out going deep they're not
gonna try you over top anyway out route
Flint so me every time he got on the
field I'm right there lined up next to
him they kept him on my side so I could
talk to him and I just talked to him the
whole game
every every bar every snap that was
thrown towards us the way he had a
breakup because he listened and I let
him know
runny it's a slant he got a breakup
they're going deep
incomplete so it's just like I just told
him like keep that confidence going keep
it going and keep it going once you make
one play You're gonna start falling to
your groove and every every play after
that forget the last play just keep
going you're gonna fall in your groove
you're gonna feel more comfortable so
that's how I pretty much coach them be
up there at the school coaching them
some more so
just gotta take one of my wing and let
them know like you got this don't worry
about what anybody else saying about you
just do your thing also yeah
Omarion man he's been like that since
he's been like that since I would say
since he got to school
she's just been like that man we knew we
just had to get him in a game he just
got a he's the same thing with money him
him and money had the same issue that
was missing me this
but like I told him like after every
play I he came to me and saw him after
every driver I'm telling him like forget
the last draft
you got your confidence back you
starting to fall back into it you're
starting to love it again don't worry
about the last play don't worry about
the last drive you still got a mortar go
out there and do more to earn you mean
you ain't did nothing yet good morning
send a little Glimpse one game you still
got more to prove you got to prove
yourself for three more years four more
years so just gotta go ahead and keep
playing that's pretty much what I tell
them I played a video game with him all
the time and I just let them know like
oh come on man we need you bro you guys
gotta come on you gotta shine dog and I
feel like oh as much he's like almost
like me
he's exclusive uh
he go out there and do his job he get
the ball he athletic he can catch run
it's just a lot that he could do that
remind me of myself he's athletic he'll
go over top of you and catch the ball
you're a great kid so it's like he's
like a brother to me man I talk to him
almost every day we always on the game
with each other and I just let them know
like just keep your confidence and keep
going we're gonna need you no matter
what and like right after the game we
got on the game uh I think Sunday
yesterday and I told him oh you back in
it now you got to continue to prove
yourself you can't get satisfied can't
get happy don't let all the outsiders
coming in trying to tell you great job
now that don't matter right now you
still got a bigger picture and that's
the feed your family and get to the next
level
but who's yours coach wrong
it's my item man
I just try to follow his footsteps man
I'm trying to get that gold jacket
nobody understand that man I wanna I
wanna go jacket so bad
yeah cause problem is my role model man
let me know and teach me everything I
can do
she doing let everyone know we knew he
could uh oh could be a big time player
which is true
a tough loss but we we never stop
fighting and that's our identity of the
team man
I mean
that's all we got to do and he's not
telling no lie
you know he let him know keep balling
man that's that's the key we're gonna
keep balling keep going crazy
we ain't proof nothing we improved
nothing yet we got two loss on our belt
hey for me on now we gotta go perfect
two losses behind us three wins behind
us we gotta Katina wanna go 1-0 every
week so that's starting this week
starting now starting today just gotta
go out there and become 1-0 every week
from here on out how you feel about
those great jerseys some things was cold
I wouldn't do wear them jerseys but I
couldn't man I want them dressed so bad
my idol played through Angie so get back
on the field it's not that easy he could
play through uh I put hamstring I can't
play with a laturated liver because if I
get hit in it again it's not gonna be
good so it's not that easy for me to
just go out there and play I mean I see
I know you see me go back out there
I thought after I heard it still went
out there and still try to do my thing
but at halftime the doctors pulled me
it's because it was good for them to put
me you don't want to have intern and
bleeding yes I'm gonna play for the
Buffaloes next year
you wouldn't know I bought a onesies bro
yeah I can't get this onesie man yeah I
was hating a couple weeks ago when y'all
see me in a onesie now every time I'm in
on Lindsay everybody started liking now
onesies I got the shoes I got everything
to match
ones just go crazy uh coach prom also
let the haters know
this week
stop hating
and nothing for you to hate about man
if you can't see what's coming with CU
football you've lost your mind you just
a flat out hater if you can't see what's
going on and what's going to transpire
over the next several months
something's wrong with you if you can't
see what's coming
yeah stop here man
you wear a onesie as a kid
you wore Wednesday as a kid uh no not
really
probably when I was a baby what did I
see myself in two years playing football
balling out doing it like doing what I
like what I love or what I like what I
love you don't feel like you'll start
with a drop nah
so you drive eligible next year yes I am
work keeps your Mentor check while
you're recover in hell up
uh I would say fishing playing the game
my girlfriend
family
just knowing I still got more to prove
pretty much
all those things help me out I mean I
ain't do ain't do nothing yet so I still
got more to prove still got family to
help out still got family uh that want
to see me win
so
I still got little brothers and sisters
that I still gotta prove myself to let
them know gotta let them have have them
follow my footsteps
so that would that would keep me going
I'm sure if you watch basketball
and watch your team a lot of different
nuggets man
I'm living I live in Colorado man I'm a
different nuggets fan now
I'm willing to stay at another three
years and I see you if that's what
happened that's what happened
one of my favorite college team as a kid
if you know me you know my favorite
college team was Florida State number
one thing that keep me motivated and
playing the game My Girlfriend my family
uh I still have little brothers and
sisters that like I said before that
gots to see me
they don't got to see me but I want them
to see me win
I love the game
without the game I'm pretty much just a
fishing guy
and I think football is like my best
attribute for real I love it I love
playing football I've been playing it
since I was little
so cool doctor pair my game to in the
NBA I'm a football player
but if I had to say I'm like LeBron
James I'm the king of the field is that
a kitty yes that is a kitty he's out
there crying for no reason fishing or
gaming if I could fish all day long
without the sun going down it would
definitely be fishing best fish to catch
largemouth bass or peacock bass but do I
want to be when I when I grow up uh a
fisherman nah
I want to be a professional football
player and also a fisherman
but you drama right
how am I jumping around on the field
I mean I could be
all right y'all it's time for Monday
Night Football who y'all got Seahawks or
Giants
they play they play today they play
tonight who do y'all got winning
let me know let me know let me know let
me know thoughts on Kelsey and Taylor
Swift I have no thoughts I mean there
are two humans
that's it I'm gonna thought
they're dating
peacock bass in Colorado no it's no
peacock bags in Colorado it gets too
cold
oh 50 50 y'all
is this come different from Jackson
State
I would say no because it's all at the
end of the day football
football's gonna be football man
get up
at the end of the day football is
football man
see how yeah
Seahawks Giants
Seahawks giant Seahawks giant see how
it's Giants dang I'm a giant fan but we
suck
oh why you say that bro
what do you say y'all suck
y'all believe in your team
yes sir
all right so it look like Seahawks won
so we're gonna come back next Monday and
with the results y'all know how we do it
what's your cat name cat's name Smokey
and Wheezy
now it's time for overreaction and not
overreaction let's get right into it
all right first we got
let's go
how how tall are you though it don't
matter still they're gonna be that size
you know what I'm saying y'all still
gonna beat me we gonna be this side it
don't matter after we started yeah I
know respect for grown man strength
when I played
y'all play football
we put it in the faster bro I'm a DBS on
my diva I don't know what that mean in
basketball what's a DVD
and basketball specializing defense I
don't know what that means
that is definitely an overreaction
Shiloh sucks at basketball he can shoot
a little bit
but that's a reaction right nah yeah
there's not beating them in basketball I
mean if you have me on the team man
that's a different story because I'm
like that I'm looking at basketball
all right next we got coach from never
celebrated after a touchdown
he don't
you clearly you just don't look at me in
the background I do
I definitely do
you never celebrate though
I celebrate every time
I'm gonna celebrate every time
yeah coach Paul never celebrate though
that's not overreaction
he don't ever celebrate the touchdown
even when he was at Jackson State and I
scored the title game then celebrate
because he don't celebrate at all
another tough onesie yes sir once he's
always going crazy got a little Hat Man
I can't wear my little hat cause I got
headphones on
does coach prom make me run a lot no if
anything he's trying to save me and I
make myself run a lot because I always
try to get in there when he tell me not
to
good at basketball yes I am go look at
my YouTube channel
Travis Hunter
I play basketball too
the touch push is impossible to stop
right yeah you're stopping that bro
I can't give you no take uh I will stop
it I can't stop it
these grown man can't even stop it it's
automatic play man it's automatic first
down
touchdown whatever they need is
automatic cannot stop it bro I don't
know how you supposed to stop it
the biggest dude biggest strongest dude
all across the line to be ready to push
it's the only way you can stop it
hmm
wait
this is one of the craziest place
these Squirtle no he didn't
bruh you got all the way over there and
then score
no that's a great Hustle
that is great Hustle
there's no way where is he out where is
he at where's he at
number seven number seven yeah we gonna
get that boy
yep he didn't score that's a great play
that's not overreaction boy that is one
of the that is one of the craziest
places I've seen
that's crazy he really got there
smacked it out good job
y'all gotta look at the top of the
screen bro
get them
I don't know what the DB thought he was
doing he definitely gotta knows no
better it's not an overreaction well I
don't know what he was thinking if it
was just jump
yeah that dude definitely helped him
though what's your favorite movie Blind
Side Longest Yard fraud all the fried
days
game plan
like all those movies
now I guess it wasn't a forward pass
because the quarterback
probably at the bar
that's not a forecast
huh
whoa
about what
hey yo
what is brobo doing
not overreaction I don't know what the
mixing water mean but I guess it's
drinks he definitely knew you too I
don't know what he got going on
oh what the
emergence flip
bro what
is not an overreaction that boy
definitely need to do it but I don't
know what he got going on
we're the most famous person in my phone
oh no should I call him
nice I'm not gonna call him
I'm not gonna call him I'm not gonna
call him let's get into it next what do
we have next
Big Man TV I've seen this already yeah
that's not a reaction I'm just a tough
bro they're gonna make a move get off me
I got there
hey
get off
get on me
touch that all right extra point excuse
me
nah it's funny that's good though
all right it's time to mix it up y'all
y'all know I love the screen
so we're gonna ring some video games
I think I'll play in what type of what
tier they are so
go to game is obviously right now 2K 24.
uh fortnite
and War Zone
no oh if I had NCAA 14
you said what oh war zone
it doesn't matter what any words on I
play I like to play rebirth so I like
both war songs I probably say one though
because that map was crazy tough but
Warzone in uh NCAA 14 if I had it
definitely top of the top
gas
I'm gonna go in
nah
2K 23
uh
Madden 24 Madden 24 yeah I used to be a
man a lot I used to play in the yard I
like the uh I like the yard I like the
yard
fun but not my favorite
GTA
I didn't play Madden 23 like that so no
we got Minecraft
Apex never play Apex OverWatch
Red Dead
Minecraft Minecraft Minecraft
I used to play Minecraft when I was a
little I'll play that
actually can you go back up to gas I
need uh the other war zone and gas too
because I I play it otherwise
other warzone's tough
there we go there we go there we go mid
Madden 23
Valentine three men
uh will pay you to take it out of my
hands Apex
red Red Dead OverWatch
for all those in there
you could take those
I don't remember playing OverWatch
not yet you could take those out my hand
I'm good on those OJ I'm good
yeah it was my my go-to right there is
crazy lineup
my if I had NCAA on my computer again
I would definitely be playing it right
there is Cash no
Apex nah
rocket League now
he fixes talk for sure nah
I don't play Apex bro
I'm good I stay with fortnite
no sir
I'm good bro fortnite I like fortnite
I'm a fortnight type of guy
I hope you're feeling better my guy I am
man feeling great feeling good
Apex is trash yeah I agree NCAA went
crazy should I start screaming on NCAA
yeah let me know
should I start screaming NCAA 14 I can
make a lead
where's lyanna
she's not home right now
show me should I start screaming on NCAA
14. y'all gotta let me know something
favorite playing college football other
than a teammate ah
I don't have one
to be honest don't
have one should I start screaming on
NCAA 14 I might
favorite non-football athlete
um
I'm not pronouncing your name right I'm
not even gonna try it bro you're not
gonna make me look like a fool
no sir
I'll watch if you did oh I might
absolutely should
are you saying
all right next up we got a blur but make
sure y'all let me know if I should
explain my NCAA 14. I'll get that
started ASAP
but first Michigan receiver
Roman missing I've seen this
definitely snack that and you hold on to
it the whole way even to the ground
that's crazy
give me that
as I want to man that's that I Gotta
Have It
that's that I Gotta Have It blue beaned
up
literally on his head
on his head literally on his head
like
can't get no better than that next
this is not a blurry y'all I'm sorry
fourth to five
you about to get safety
keep going keep going oh why y'all
diving
first down oh snatches
bro that had to be the longest play of
the weekend there's no way they gave
them that or he got that right that's
crazy that's not a blur we got to go
next Bowling Green receiver
that's a nice play though
is this the blurry that's gotta be a
blur yeah oh
do you just get someone here
nah that's a blue
oh his head oh my God
he snagged that mug
he went to grab that one
blue
everybody just making spectacular
catches this week but I couldn't even
get a replay bro
couldn't even get a replay bro
it's crazy to me
Perry the Platypus
and it's crazy because it didn't look
like he caught it but he actually caught
it
like it was just sitting on his stomach
or his chest and he just
sitting there uh crap
that stuff
blur Nation
all right man before we get out of here
upcoming game you know we gotta talk
about it every week like I said last
week got to go out there when it can't
be a close game gotta go dominate no
nobody cares if it's you win by a
touchdown it's a w
nobody cares if you lose about three
points it's still a loss it's still a
loss on your record it's not a tie game
on your record it's not you lost on your
record I mean you uh lost by three on
your record
is you lost or you win so we got to go
out there and just dominate man we gotta
either go we gotta go out there and win
we gotta come out fast discipline
ready to play hair on fire
click your teeth platypus I can't do it
right
I can't do that bro
but yeah we gotta go out there and
dominate we gotta go out there and win
we can't uh we can't go on
oh and three for the last three weeks
man we got to go out there we got to get
another win we gotta get our confidence
back we gotta go out there and dominate
go out there and show the world that we
here still despise them them two lost
nobody cares about the two loss no more
it's over with now it's time to get back
on the winning streak start to start to
get our character back started let
everybody know it's time to win and we
ain't got time to lose any more Got No
Room for losses
but yeah we just stay tuned
for next Monday thank y'all I'm gonna
get back to y'all with the NCAA 14 live
stream I'm gonna get back to y'all with
the Seahawks and Giants next Monday and
uh ASU game
and stay blessed up stay prayed up see
your host Travis Hunter 12 talks and we
out
[Music]